this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
farrah's and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
today's episode we're taking a journey
down memory lane to check out some of
jonathan's favorite weapons from the
past year this is probably the most
detailed in-game model of an akm i have
ever seen really really nice to see a a
very rare historic firearm depicted not
only in a video game but something where
you really get hands-on with it like
that jonathan and the whole team here at
gamespot just want to say thank you to
everyone who's watched the show over the
last year we really appreciate your
support and of course if you'd like to
help out the royal army's museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video and if you enjoy this kind
of content make sure to keep an eye out
for our upcoming new series lowdown a
show where we take a look at the history
and impact of some of the most iconic
weapons in gaming from the shotgun and
geralt's silver sword through to the m1
garand and the desert eagle jonathan
will be making plenty of appearances
over on that show too so make sure to
check that out right let's take a look
at some of jonathan's highlights from
the past year
all right this is a really really quite
a fun one for me because this weapon if
i can call it a weapon is something
that's actually from the royal armouries
collection and i have it with me today
it's not identical to what we see on
screen as i'll explain in a moment but i
am about 90 odd percent sure that the
aoka pistol is based directly on this
specific object so the difference is the
big one i mean the sticks the same
pretty much and the wire wrapping it
onto the
together the big difference is the
barrel which in the game is some sort of
an iron tube whereas on the real thing
it's a 20 millimeter
cartridge case
and to make it a barrel all they've done
is
dent in the top of it and drill that in
the center to create not only a touch
hole or a vent if you prefer but a pan
for the priming powder and that's
probably the biggest divergence from the
game version this is really a medieval
handgun or hand cannon recreated using
the cartridge case as a barrel
and you need that depression
to fill with powder so that there's
something to go flash
so that the gun goes back what we see in
rust is the player is striking the
barrel with a rock and it's creating a
spark
off the iron or steel barrel and the
sparks somehow going into the gun
setting it off it's not completely
implausible but it's pretty daft so
whereas this is not not a very good
weapon and but it would fire for for one
shot the one in the game i'm not
confident would work at all they've kind
of covered that by showing it require
multiple random hits from the rock to
actually fire
so
they put that level of thought into it
of course wow um this is the first i'm
seeing of
taco i've heard a lot of people talk
about it seeing a lot written about it
that it has a lot of realism in its
depiction of firearm and just from that
short clip right away
i can see what they're talking about so
we've got the the makarov or makarov
very much a cold war pistol very much a
sidearm it's not not really a combat
weapon although people with the training
can obviously use it that way and it's
really nicely modeled the sound effects
are probably the best i've heard just
from that short clip
but that that sounds like a gun being
fired in a building perhaps um i don't
know how much it changes as you move in
and out of spaces perhaps we'll see and
the way it's handled is really cool the
brass check the press check that he does
to make sure that it's chambered around
a bit of a modern thing but um it is
done and it is in there and you get to
see the cartridge in the in the gun
okay um i gather people have been keen
for me to see the gunsmith section of of
tarkov and i can see why that's really
really impressive the sheer variety that
we see in here cosmetic as well as what
looks like some pretty practical changes
that you can make um i think i'd
probably spend my most of my time
in that section of the game and not
actually shooting anybody because the
ability to
virtually customize guns like that is
that's practically a game in itself
that's really good i really like that
i'm gonna have to get a second mortgage
and get a gaming pc
i'm gonna pause there
where to start
it's a real gun as i'm sure people have
already googled a 2.7 millimeter bullet
incredibly small and the gun itself is
incredibly small so the actual cartridge
length and is tiny as well just get it
out the way this thing would have zero
stopping power a bullet of that
incredibly lightweight traveling at that
very low speed is not pulling off head
shots at
50 meters or whatever we just saw i have
to chuckle at the um dainty way that the
the character handles the thing and sort
of squeezes it between his thumb and
forefinger so as you can see as you
would have seen from other videos on
this i'm sure it is
tiny it's as tiny as it's seen on screen
in fact
i think it's
tinier as to how it works in the game
yeah they've got that right imagine
doing this in uh under fire press the
magazine catch tab on the base to pull
the magazine out and then with a tiny
belt of magazines or something pushing a
fresh one and yes it [ __ ] as it as it
does
in the game it's a real gun um but it's
not a real gun in the sense that it
doesn't kill anyone but it might
irritate them i suppose
the most cowboy gun ever i think the uh
single action army cult we have a nice
first generation 1870s vintage example
and the um the red dead 2 representation
is really good and as we saw in the clip
you can clean the guns which i thought
was a really nice touch maintaining your
firearms was an important thing to do
and it's rare to see it done in a game
so that's really cool although of course
a simple white with an oily rag is not
usually enough to clean up uh rust like
that the way it functions
again pretty spot on the first person
view pretty pretty good it's a little
weird how
he hangs on the on the hammer so that
when he pulls the trigger the hammer
flies forward out from under his thumb
almost no reason why that wouldn't work
but
not really good practice because if you
slow down the hammer there's a small
chance that the round might not go off
generally the rate of fire is what you'd
expect from a single action gun i.e
[ __ ] it fire it
pocket firing you can't pull through on
the trigger to fire a shot
now that's a really interesting gun that
we've seen there that's the the viper
mark 1 which is a british experimental
submachine gun of the very end of the
second world war so this this thing does
show up in my new book on british
ballpark firearms because it's one of
the relatively early attempts
really really nice to see a
very rare historic firearm depicted not
only in a video game but something where
you can really get hands-on with it like
that looks to work as it probably does
work we don't quite know because we're
not going to shoot it it's the only one
that i know of that exists there may be
others let me know if you do no but i
don't think there are and um when it's
pulled up to the to the eye sort of
aimed fire you'll see that you can see
there are no sights and it's kind of
cumbersome even in vr and that's because
this was designed as a commando weapon
for assaulting over a beach and you
could sort of see from how it's shaped
that it's actually fought under the arm
one-handed use
so you're looking where you're shooting
and you're grasping it under the arm
giving you loads of control over recoil
but you've got no right no ability to
aim that's a fascinating historic
firearm and i'm really glad to see it in
this game
we've got another mp5 this one that i've
grabbed is it's an sd the suppressed
version which is what we saw being used
just then i quite like the way that one
was depicted i'm a connoisseur of um
video game mp5s and that one pretty much
nailed the mp5 in general and the sd
specifically the sound effects are not
far off what you actually hear in real
life when you shoot this thing or you
hear this thing shot people often say
it's so quiet all you hear is the bolt
clicking back and forth which is mostly
true slight pop from the muzzle the loud
clang of the bolt moving you're gonna
know something's going on but you might
not know that it's a firearm and this
was for the decades was the default
definitive suppressed submachine gun
wasn't really worth using anything else
provided you could afford this
i like that if it wasn't for the fact
you only get one shot that's almost like
an ideal zombie weapon that's a 12 gauge
single barrel break open shotgun they
were very common in the old west that
looked like it might be in either
johnson or
stevens or something and it's obviously
been modified with a quite a cool
hatchet attachment and is is drastically
cut down if this is like 1880s and the
cartridges are black powder you would
want a
smokeless powder loaded cartridge
basically because if you're firing black
powder out of that shorter barrel it's
going to be pretty weak the burnt rate
of black powder is is different and
wouldn't be hugely effective so we'll
have to assume that those are nitro
cartridges um incidentally the
cartridges looks quite authentic there's
a tendency in games to just stick modern
looking cartridges which don't look
totally out of place but
those with a different color and the
detail of the headstamp that actually
looked like some they dug out some late
19th century early 20th century maybe
cartridges to model there
strangely enough the first thing i've
noticed about the ak here was the
ejection pattern if you've seen a real
ak fired it's got a really aggressive
forward and upward ejection pattern so
slight slightly weaker and off to the
side ping something in my brain that
wasn't quite right there that's
something you're only going to get
absolutely right if you've had a camera
behind a real ak shooting or have found
some footage of it doing that the other
the other thing from this first person
perspective is the depiction of recoil
which i think is good the the ak is an
excellent weapon but the impulse of a
relatively powerful intermediate
cartridge and the shape of the buttstock
and the mass of the bolt carrier
slamming back means it does tend to
jump so although the ak was designed
very much for automatic fire it was two
to three rounds from the shoulder
anything more than that and it does does
become a bit uncontrollable and i think
that comes across well um i've grabbed
an ak not because none of you've seen an
ak before you have this is one of my
favorite objects in the collection i've
chosen this russian type 2 as we as we
tend to call them because of this
on the butt gp dylan one slash seven and
long story short this belonged to
colonel gregory p dillon of the one
seven air cavalry this is actually from
vietnam and it's it's really something
to hold this every time i pick it up
okay pause well we're off to a good
start there with the browning automatic
rifle the m1918a
this is well modeled well implemented i
think they're running on the
slower of the two rates of fire makes
you realize listening and listening to
that and watching it how you know a
well-trained soldier firing rapidly you
know
can easily match that sort of low 400
rounds per minute or 300 and something i
think it was the other sort of minor
nerdy detail is the lack of the carrying
handle which is also correct because
most of the a2s you'll see now as well
as probably having their bipods will
have a carrying handle on them which is
another kind of moving toward like
machine gun thing well that feature was
not fitted during the second world war
so these guys have done their research
it's well modeled it's well represented
apparent recoil rate of fire all of that
seems to be pretty good and the effect
on target as well you know firing bursts
short bursts of twos and threes as you
probably would be doing and the enemies
going down so there's none of this
bullet sponge nonsense
it's our old friend the kalashnikov ak
in this case the akm the modernized ak
introduced in 1959 and at this point
pretty much the most common this is
probably the most detailed in-game model
of an akm i have ever seen lots of
detail there in the 3d model itself so
much so that i'm able to nitpick
tiny details like the front of the
gas block here it might
be the angle it might be me
but i don't think so this is an akm gas
block so note the ramp here
and the shape of the front the gas block
on this rifle is much more ak pattern so
the earlier version when you do this
good a job on an in-game gun this is
your reward you get nitpicked
if i wasn't looking at a front
right court of view of this thing i
would not have spotted that
we have the the pkp uh the petronagas as
it's called which is essentially an
assault variant of the pkm entirely
appropriate to see it in this game of
course and what i'm what i'm struck by
here in the loading animation is some
really nice attention to detail where
the player character lifts up the feed
tray and checks visually checks the
chamber to see that the gun is clear
which is something that video games
don't normally trouble themselves with
but in any kind of armed force is
absolutely essentially part of the drill
part of the manual of arms so that right
there tells you that you are playing
a milsim i really like the reloading
animation in general here because
it feels
the gun model
feels like it has more weight it doesn't
just feel like one of those um belt fed
assault rifle like machine guns that we
get in first person shooters it's more
kind of
he's having to manhandle it turn it over
fit the ammo box put everything back
into position it looks like it might
weigh something which i think is it
helps immerse you in what's going on
thanks again for watching if you enjoy
this kind of content please make sure to
like this video and subscribe to the
channel as we'll have new episodes of
firearms expert reacts every saturday
and new episodes of loadout every sunday
again please check out the links in the
description of the video if you want to
help support the royal armouries and
we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you